can you both talk about your thoughts
around just the u.s government holding
bitcoin all the regulations that's going
on currently and like does that stifle
innovation does not can you just give me
your thoughts around all that the u.s
government stupidly stole their bitcoin
right they had ross ross albrecht's
bitcoin they sold it they sold it to
timer tim draper you know over in
silicon valley right they've been
sellers of bitcoin stupidly um they
they're stupid the chinese government is
stupid for kicking out the miners and um
they don't they don't you know bitcoin
avoids narcissistic kleptocrats and the
u.s china countries that have mental
problems it doesn't go well
so will the u.s change i think what
we've said is that you've got the states
have the ability to
reformulate a course of action and take
on the federal government so that's
where it's going to come from texas
wyoming florida are leading so
maybe the texas
teachers pension fund or something like
that or the texas general municipality
pension fund says we're going to put a
bitcoin position that starts a ripple
effect uh for all over from state to
state uh it could see that happening but
at the federal level i don't see it
happening because uh for the reasons you
know that i just said the the other
piece of this uh is we recently had um
uh whit gibbs coming from compass mining
and he
i don't know if he meant to say it or uh
slipped and said that the united states
government was mining bitcoin in the
middle of the country let's say that
there's a 50 50 probability whether
that's happening or not what is the us's
play if you were the president of the
united states and you said okay here's a
situation i'm facing currently we've
talked about that
and then here's this new technology do
you
shut down the federal reserve and go buy
a bunch of bitcoin do you start mining
do you just make the rules a little bit
more relaxed so that you can incentivize
uh entrepreneurs and innovators like how
do you think about like
what should they do
michael saylor the fed chairman
or the treasury secretary why and say um
take the game book the the playbook user
using over a microstrategy and apply to
the federal government please and do it
fast so that we don't get
disintermediated out of the 21st century
because at this rate we're going to be
blown out of the water by the smaller
more nimble more agile smarter bitcoin
countries i think i think they don't
care about um i think you know they're
in the mindset of we have the us
treasuries and the us dollar and we're
dominant then but i it makes sense
geopolitically that they would be mining
bitcoin just as probably all many
nations are mining bitcoin in order to
move
secretly
around the internet and around the globe
because it's it's you know untraceable
money and you don't need a 747 to move
your gold around and you can just
you know finance projects dark you know
black ops you know with uh bitcoin so i
think that's probably if if they're
mining bitcoin that's probably what
they're doing not necessarily to
stockpile
like any uh store of value plus you have
to if somebody saw me oh the federal
government's mining bitcoin in the
middle of america somewhere i'd have to
ask well
is it the same federal government that
is operating outside of the
democratic process that gave us all
kinds of political problems in the last
five 10 20 years i mean if they are
mining it is are we going to be sharing
in that bounty or are they going to
steal no i mean they could be using our
resources to go mine bitcoin and then
they could go leave the country
right so i mean these guys are like i
said they're the corruption is uh
it's on a scale it's off the charts so i
i trust them for a one second i do know
for
a fact because a person who worked at
the organization told me
that in let's call it 2012 2013 one of
the federal law enforcement agencies uh
they wanted to conduct uh cryptocurrency
related investigations and as part of
that uh they wanted to do some
undercover type work uh they
either did not believe they could get
approved or
went for the approval got denied for a
budget approval to purchase bitcoin so
instead they said well they always give
us approval for computers and so they
went ahead and they put in a budget
approval for
mining equipment and they ended up
mining bitcoin now one they were able to
actually get their hands on bitcoin two
was virgin bitcoin so you couldn't trace
it et cetera and then that was used for
uh investigations now
i don't want to uh exaggerate in terms
of my guess is that that was a very
small amount right and i don't think
that people would count that as like the
government is holding bitcoin right i
think when we talk about that we're
talking about it in terms of it's on you
know treasury federal reserve this is
part of our uh our kind of national
strategy
outside of just that of putting michael
saylor or somebody like that to almost
pull off a speculative attack
what else would you do he sees the
miners in texas
u.s seize the miners hell yeah that's
probably what they're thinking about
that's the easiest way for the u.s
government to get into bitcoin
businesses go down to those huge
operations that are in texas now and
seize them like they stole they took the
gold in the in the 30s right they seized
everyone's gold the federal government
could seize all those miners in texas
that could trigger a serious conflict
with the state of texas so i was just
going to ask if they were to go to
because that's a pretty bold
the government under eminent domain uh
you know under under the auspices of
national security can do
anything they want to do they may take
your shoes off at the airport
again it's getting worse and worse and
people and the people's rights are being
more and more abused so they they would
go to that that would be from in my view
that would be the easiest way for the
federal government to get in the game
pretty fast
that's what i mean like our guests are
frequent guests that we've had on kai's
report jim rickards who works with the
cia war gaming financial war and he
always said to us on kaiser report that
the u.s government would seize all of
the gold
held on behalf of other nations so we
hold a lot of gold
of our own the united states gold but we
also own gold we hold gold for other
nations afghanistan
right well yeah but nations like germany
uh correct
yeah our allies that we would seize
their goals they just reneged on the on
the afghani goal yeah yeah the afghans
basically uh whatever whoever you want
to say is in power now right depending
on if it's the official iran official
basically said give us our money back
and they said when i give it to you
because we don't know who who's in
charge yeah so that's what they would do
that's
the similar mindset would happen with um
whatever
you know bitcoin miners that makes sense
like we've already seen with china what
they what they're thinking or how
they're operating and i think it's a do
you know this
thucydides trap this relationship
between the us and china the creditor
and debtor
nation going forward is what to look at
for what we might do